kicking off ETS Kardashian ketchup  Northwest and Penelope Disick shows some  cousin love it's all love I love it  Rob Kardashian shared a priceless pic of  his daughter dream in a stroller while  his nieces north and Penelope sweetly  touched her head the proud ed also  gushed about his little girl in this  solo shot that read I love this woman I  will never tell her no I feel like we  are so blessed to have the best support  system and the best family  then there's Kim Kourtney Khloe and  Kylie Jenner enjoying a sister day Kim K  joined 19 year old Kylie at a photo  shoot and teased her little sis on set  for her famously enhanced pout gang is  shooting and Kourtney can't seem to  catch a break from Khloe as she goofs  off during their joint workout now let's  go  [Music]  you